l'entretien dix minutes vous allez
commencer par vous présenter et puis
après on va essayer de voir vers quel
point son projet vous orienter
léo 19 ans a déjà une expérience de
caisse et de mise en rayon dans la
grande distribution il fait partie des
500 postulants attirés par la journée de
recrutement organisée par le leclerc de
bois d'arcy c'est une opportunité c'est
une chance et il faut toujours multiplié
ses possibilités de travail n'ont du
coup toujours postuler dans différents
endroits et quand j'ai vu même si ici
moi je suis à maurepas donc ça une horde
ici même c'est une heure de trajet pour
u travail ça n'empêche pas en fait quoi
de se déplacer en tout cas bouchers
poissonniers boulanger employé libre
service les entretiens était possible
sans rendez vous avec ou sans cv une
opération organisée au niveau national
dans 460 centre 65 postes sont
actuellement à pourvoir dans cette
enseigne un premier échange qui permet
de de d'accrocher sur certains sur
certains points et de pouvoir le cas
échéant s'ils allaient profils sont sûr
intéressant pour nous les revoir sur un
deuxième un deuxième entretien un peu
plus approfondie le but c'était de
toucher un maximum de personnes j'ai
envie de dire un minimum de temps pour
pouvoir répondre à nos besoins des
visites des coulisses de l'hypermarché
étaient aussi proposées lors de cette
journée des cdi des cdd ou encore de
l'alternance était proposée pour les
eaux le recruteur envisage de le
rappeler d'ici 15 jours pour un nouvel
entretien
[Musique]